merci monsieur le président
oserais-je dire honte à vous
honte à vous
vous êtes laissés bâillonner par le 47,1
de la Constitution et le gouvernement et
vous voulez maintenant bayonner votre
position c'est un scandale
[Applaudissements]
l'article 38 n'a jamais été utilisé sans
faire de ma part dans cette émission
vous le faites parce que vous avez
incapable de défendre vos arguments tout
au long de ces 5 jours
nous sommes exprimés devant les Français
avec nos arguments avec notre projet de
société et vous vous êtes couché
je le dis
alors mes chers collègues oui mais je
suis le président vous allez pouvoir
utiliser l'Artic 38 le règlement vous en
donne la possibilité
mais nous serons consultés avant cela
mais je tiens à rappeler quand même
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
du 11 juillet 2019 notez cela mes chers
amis le Conseil confirme la réserve
d'interprétation déjà formulé en 2015
selon laquelle il appartiendra au
président de séance d'appliquer cette
limitation dans le temps cette clôture
du débat ce bâillonnage
cette limitation eu le temps de temps de
parole en veillant au respect des
exigences de clarté et de sincérité du
débat parlementaire
et bien nous ferons nous ferons les
recours auprès du conseil pour savoir si
c'est unité a été préservé dans cette
musique
[Musique]